qui est 75 j'aime déjà vu 300 vues c'est
énorme en 11 minutes
[Musique]
comment on présente la vidéo il faut que
ça soit très court
c'était la dame qui a fait le tournage
aujourd'hui qui a fait des Fatal Bazooka
qui t'a cagoule
[Musique]
son super content de faire Tik Tok même
c'est eux des fois qui me donnent des
idées en leur propose une musique et
après ça eux en leur fait rechercher des
idées de danse ou donc ça permet aussi
du coup de faire travailler
l'imagination et la créativité des
résidents
[Musique]
c'est elle qui ont décidé ça et ils nous
ont demandé si on était d'accord moi je
dis tout de suite oui je suis d'accord
j'ai demandé à mes enfants pour ma fille
a dit tu sais j'ai pas vu mais j'ai vu
sur autre chose
et j'étais pas contente que je le fasse
on va d'ici à 17h ça regarde si tu veux
pas te le dis si tu veux tu le fais et
tu dis oui juste ça fait plaisir à tout
le monde ici
[Musique]
un petit peu comme nous ils avaient à
coeur de montrer qu'un EHPAD c'est pas
mon roi qu'ici s'amuse et qu'il faut pas
forcément avoir peur d'entrer en EHPAD
on a vu beaucoup de choses négatives sur
les EHPAD et il faut les montrer puisque
c'est pas normal mais c'est pas comme ça
dans tous les EHPAD et nos résidences
vous les montrer justement que il y a
certains EHPAD où ça se passe bien et où
il y a des EHPAD on s'ennuie pas
[Musique]
la couronne